Bem-vindos, ao
MOOC de programação funcional FP101x.
Eu estou realmente feliz que nós podemos fazer
este MOOC com exercícios e
tudo mais.
Vamos começar
imediatamente. Uma coisa que eu queria
dizer a vocês antes de continuarmos
é que este é um MOOC sobre programação
funcional, que é o que o título
"FP101 functional programming" diz. Este não
é um curso de Haskell, estamos usando
Haskell
como uma linguagem funcional mas não
estamos aprendendo a programar Haskell em si.
Deixe-me contar a vocês um pouco
de uma história.
Eu viajo muito, vou a conferências,
dando cursos etc.
e durante estas viagens eu tenho
tempo suficiente para assistir TV.
Certa noite eu estava trocando de canais
aleatoriamente
e havia um daqueles programas
de sobrevivência.
no qual um homem estava tentando
montar um acampamento a noite e
tentando fazer uma fogueira
mas seus fósforos estavam molhados.
Ele poderia ter entrado em pânico e falado:
Meus fósforos estão molhados eu não
consigo fazer uma fogueira.
O que ele fez em vez disso foi pegar
o seu telefone celular
e sua faca e ele
removeu a bateria de seu celular,
abriu a bateria
e então a bateria começou a entrar
em combustão.
Foi isso que ele usou para fazer uma fogueira.
E esta é a mesma
atitude que eu quero ensinar a você
neste curso.
Enquanto estamos aprendendo a programar
funcionalmente com Haskell, então
Haskell será nossos fósforos,
quando no trabalho você não tiver
fósforos disponíveis
você ainda pode programar funcionalmente.
As vezes você tem que esmagar seu
telefone celular
e abrir sua bateria para começar uma fogueira.
Não pense que este curso e sobre
Haskell, por si só, nós vamos ensinar
programação funcional
usando Haskell.
Certo, vamos
começar então.
Qual é o problema que estamos tentando
resolver? O problema
é chamado de “crise do software”.
Todos nós sabemos
como desenvolvedores que escrever código é
muito difícil.
Estamos escrevendo programas enormes e
o que precisamos fazer é reduzir o
tempo
e o custo do desenvolvimento.
Queremos entregar software rápido
e queremos entregar software correto.
A questão é
como podemos fazer programas
de tal forma que estejamos confiantes de
que nosso programa funciona
e como podemos fazer código
de tal forma que este código seja
entregue rápido.
Ele não leva anos para ser entregue
mas leva
meses ou o quanto precisar para ser.
Uma forma de fazer isso, e nós vemos isso agora
em todas as linguagens de programação modernas,
é adicionar recursos à nossas linguagens
isso permite programas serem escritos
de forma clara e concisa e num alto nível de
abstração.
E as técnicas que usamos nestas
linguagens modernas
são todas baseadas em programação funcional.
Estas técnicas
são todas baseadas em conceitos do
cálculo lambda.
E Haskell é uma
linguagem funcional que é pura e
portanto
um veículo realmente bom para ensinar
estes conceitos.
Linguagens funcionais,
portanto, fornecem um framework
muito elegante
para escrever código num alto nível
de abstração.
Mas como eu disse, Haskell é apenas
nosso veículo.
O que aprendermos neste curso, vocês
serão capazes de aplicar
em qualquer linguagem mesmo que vocês
programem em assembly
ou Java ou PHP
ou JavaScript, todas as idéias que vocês
irão aprender aqui
vocês podem aplicar imediatamente
em qualquer linguagem que
estão felizes em usar.
O que é uma linguagem de programação
funcional?
As ideias sobre isso
variam, não há uma definição
real clara.
Se pegarmos uma abordagem muito
purista uma linguagem funcional
é uma linguagem na qual programamos
usando funções matemáticas.
E essa definição se aplica a Haskell,
que é uma linguagem pura, uma das
muito poucas
linguagens de programação funcional que
são puras. Mas é claro que
quando eu digo que vamos usar estas
técnicas para programar também em outras
linguagens
não podemos usar esta definição.
O que usaremos neste curso é a
seguinte definição:
programação funcional
é um estilo de programação na qual
expressões são mais importantes do que
usar declarações.
O que queremos fazer é: queremos
compor programas usando expressões
e estas expressões entregam um valor, então
pegamos duas expressões que entregam um
valor
e compomos elas em uma expressão maior.
Compare isso com escrever
seus programas usando declarações.
Quando vocês compõem declarações, as
declarações tem um side-effect implícito
no global state e eles
comunicam valores por este global
state.
Enquanto que em um estilo de
programação
baseado em expressões retorna
valores
e compomos estes valores diretamente.
Uma linguagem de programação funcional
é uma linguagem que suporta e
encoraja
escrever código usando expressões.
Como eu disse antes, a maioria
das linguagens modernas
agora suportam esse estilo.
E elas suportam o estilo
especificamente através de
expressões lambda.
Veremos exemplos de programação
funcional
em varias e varias linguagens
à medida que progredimos
com este curso. Vamos
iniciar com nosso primeiro fragmento
de código aqui.
Isso é um pouco de Java antiquado
no qual computamos  a soma de
de inteiros de um a dez.
A forma com que faremos isso,
como eu disse, no estilo imperativo
tradicional, que é baseado em fazer
declarações. A primeira coisa que fazemos
é declarar uma variável total
de tipo int. Inicializamos ela com zero
e então escrevemos um for loop com uma
variável loop.
Este int i, que vocês veem ali, vamos
atribui-lo a esta variável total:
variável total + i. Aqui vocês veem que
o programa está escrito
em um estilo imperativo.
Temos declarações,
temos um estado mutável e
imperativamente executa declaração
após declaração.
atualizando o estado para computar o
resultado.
Agora aqui está como vocês escreveriam o
mesmo programa
em Haskell. A primeira coisa que vocês
veem é que isto
é muito mais conciso, mas outra coisa
é que não existe declarações. São
apenas duas expressões.
A expressão que vocês veem
aqui
a direita. Um ponto ponto dez.
Cria uma lista de inteiros de um a
dez.
E então, apenas somamos estes
inteiros.
Então, aqui vocês veem que compomos
o código tendo uma expressão.
Uma que cria uma lista de um a dez
e então aplicamos este valor
a uma função sum que somará
para nós. No Java 8
vocês conseguem escrever o mesmo
código
usando streams, vamos
nos aprofundar em Java 8 em uma lição
futura mas por enquanto aqui
está a forma que
fazemos em Haskell.
Obrigado
e vejo vocês na segunda parte.